hey you guys movie retrospective time
going back to the 80s this time around
which we usually do we do the 80s a lot
although i kind of feel like we do the
70s more uh this is a movie that came
out in early 1986. it's weird because
i was looking it up earlier wikipedia
has it right it actually did come out in
february of 1986 but a bunch of other
sites like imdb and stuff have it listed
as 1985. but i don't really know why
but uh this is the movie house
now
this movie as well as the sequel
uh house to the second story
i feel like those two movies were on
cable all
the [ __ ] time because i think i saw
both of these movies at least
two or three dozen times when i was
growing up i wasn't in the united states
at the time i was in brazil so i didn't
catch it on cable but they they this was
even this movie was even popular in
brazil
but we were renting it
yeah because i feel well the cover of
this of the first one is great with like
that uh with that that zombie hand like
ring in the doorbell and says ding dong
you're dead on it um so it had like a
really really great cover so i feel like
it was kind of like one that got rented
a lot uh of times
um and this movie i didn't even realize
until i was re-watching this because
i've like watched it several times
subsequently i didn't actually realize
that this had been directed by
uh steve miner who did um friday the
13th two and three uh and also was
produced by sean s cunningham who also
uh produced friday the 13th two and
three among other things uh he also did
last house on the left the wes craven
movie and it was written by fred decker
who did night of the creeps and monster
squad
so this really has like oh and uh also
harry uh manfredini the guy that did uh
the music for all the friday the 13th
movies uh he did the music for this as
well it has a good it has a good score
it does i really like the music for this
and it's it's funny because this is kind
of like i had forgotten how strange this
movie is
uh the second one is probably weirder
uh and there's actually three sequels to
this um none of they're all standalone
like they don't really have anything to
do with one another uh other than just
being kind of weird or at least the
first two are kind of weird there's
something kind of spielbergian about the
the tone of this movie though imagine if
spielberg did kind of like a
horror comedy
it feels like that it has a very
middle-class america
mom apple pie and chevrolet feel to it
it just feels very american for that era
i like it but then it's like bonkers
yeah like the story is just so
weird like i said it's not as weird as
the second one i feel like the second
one this one is
for sure a horror comedy
the second one i think is like way more
comedy and the like less horror this one
is kind of like a balance between the
two but it's still like a really strange
because i think what ended up happening
was that the original script of this was
um you remember twilight zone in the
movie yeah which came out in 1983 which
i think we did a review of it a while
back which that's one of my favorite
movies uh one of my favorite anthology
movies for sure
so i kind of feel like after that came
out
the original script for this movie was
actually going to be one segment of an
anthology movie that was inspired by
twilight zone the movie
so i feel like a lot of the creatures
and stuff that turn up in this are sort
of like almost paying direct homage to
some of the monsters particularly in the
um
you know in the segment with anthony and
like the crazy monsters like the you
know the the one that's kind of like it
was a an updating of you know the kid
that could wish people into the corn
field uh you know and it had like all
these kind of wacky monsters in it it
has this kind of has that kind of vibe
to it but you can tell that it may be
started out as a darker story because it
also has like you know kids in peril it
has like the whole ptsd vietnam veteran
type angle to it as well so like i said
this is one of those movies like from
the 80s that
you really can't replicate this tone
because it's just so odd
you know what i'm saying
i kind of see what you're saying but
maybe because i grew up with movies like
this it seems normal to me well yeah it
seemed normal to me as well yeah uh it
only seemed weird to me like in
retrospect i guess yeah i was trying to
look at it at the context of the time
yeah like uh the vietnam veteran angle
was perfect because
that's how old the boomers were at the
time that this was going on your vietnam
veterans were the same age they wouldn't
have been that old yeah you know what i
mean yeah a vietnam veteran would have
been in his uh 30s
you know yeah like this
man what's that yeah like this guy is
yeah this character so that's still
young so they were marketed to them and
they were in the middle class by this
point or supposedly depending on what
state you lived in you know and what
your job was
and uh he's a successful writer and a
lot of boomers vietnam veterans
[ __ ] fit that profile i mean a lot of
them were in hollywood you know that's
true that were
[Music]
boomers boomer vietnam veterans they
were living like that who's this special
effects guy who was uh basically
doing that same thing going around the
conventions and making movies uh who tom
sabine tom savini yeah so
in a way the the main character is kind
of like a tom savini
in a way he's a horror writer yeah
who's going to conventions all the time
and a vietnam veteran and
yeah it's the same basic demographics
that
thomas yeah that's true
that's true
so it's not that weird yeah when you
look at it in the context of the time
and he's kind of an all-american joe
and he inherits this damn house and it
turns out
he believes the house is haunted and it
had a lot of good touches to the story
you know his aunt his aunt who raised
him
left behind these mysterious paintings
that were that were used as clues to
find certain things out that the house
could do you know
kind of reminded me of raw head wrecks
with the with the uh
um
the stained glass window that had the
the the clues in it and [ __ ] you know it
was
kind of a good little touch you know
i did actually like that i think
honestly i kind of think the best thing
about this movie is the weirdness yeah
uh the the funny relationship between
uh the carrick the main character roger
cobb who's played by william cat and his
neighbor played by george wendt yeah uh
you know i like that and the creatures
are great like just the wacky like
practical effects in this yeah i
remember in the context of the time
the creatures actually looked a lot more
real than they looked now like you know
the costume of the viet you know the
vietnam veteran the skeleton guy from
back from vietnam what was his name
again bull or
what was that character bull right well
yeah it was bull from nightcore but the
actor's name is richard mall richard
mall but what was the name of the damn
character he was big ben big ben that's
what it was
yeah the big ben outfit
i remembered it looking pretty
convincing i see it now at least on hd
it looks
kind of like something out of damn power
rangers or something you know it's not
it's not convinced but it's still a good
costume it's a practical effect
that is actually i thought that was a
costume with richard mullen it's not
it's a puppet that's an animatronic
puppet the 3d man walking around with
the m60 yeah i don't believe it that was
a man in a suit i mean i think sometimes
it was a man on a suit but a lot of
times it was a big it was a big huge
animatronic puppet maybe when they
zoomed in on it but when he was running
around in the house with that m60 that
was that was a man
it had to be yeah it probably was but
like i said they did have uh it wasn't
always that like sometimes it was like a
big animatronic puppet which like i said
they did really did a lot of like
amazing like animatronic puppet work
yeah it looked good it looked good it
was entertaining yeah it's not realistic
no it wasn't realistic but this movie
the premise of this movie is not
realistic so you just kind of have to
like
the whole tone is just fun
haunted house fun
there is some creepy [ __ ] to it so it
didn't have to look realistic in the
context of the boot yeah it was just had
to be entertaining it was
so like i said this almost kind of
reminded me and it was interesting
because i didn't realize at first that
this had been
originally intended to be part of a
uh you know anthology that was like a
homage to the twilight zone the movie
because this actually really does remind
me of that segment of the twilight zone
movie with you know anthony and the
monsters and stuff because that one was
like kind of dark and creepy too but
then it had like this wacky like kind of
uh weird surreal cartoonish kind of
thing you know what's weird about this
that i didn't realize this movie was
actually rated r
which i don't really think it needed to
be
um because a lot of the violence and
stuff in it
it's not gor it's not gory it's not it's
mostly like kind of cartoony like
puppety type of monsters yeah the
context of the time this may have been
before what was it nc 17 and pg-13 may
have not been around at that no pg-13
came around in 84 i want to say because
i think it was like gremlins or a movie
like that yeah that kind of inspired me
gremlins came out like a year or two
before this i put it at the same level
as gremlins actually yeah it's kind of
like a similar yeah it's like a similar
tone to gremlin so i guess there was
like that kind of thing going all out of
the 80 in the 80s yeah i don't see how
it would have been rated r no i don't
see i don't see that either like i said
maybe it wasn't
no it was it was um but i just don't i
don't really know why it needed to be
like i said because this seems like a
classic pg-13 yeah you could let kids
watch this yeah i mean i don't i
wouldn't be bothered by kids watching
this no there's nothing gross in it no
it's like i said there was any sexual
innuendo in it really not really no the
no nudity um no blood i don't think well
maybe a little bit but it's not like not
anything real egregious some about the
sensors they thought that it should have
been a rated r which i don't agree with
that no i don't either maybe it was more
like thematic elements because like i
said it doesn't seem real violent and
like i said it's almost more there's
some dark [ __ ] in it but it's mostly a
comedy today it had been a pg
yeah easily yeah but yeah so the story
behind this like i said you have william
cat who um had been in horror movies
before obviously he was in cary back in
1976
with his big fabulous peter franklin
yeah he did that was the name of the
character yeah and he was also i don't
know how much people in other countries
like know about this but there was a
show called the greatest american hero
yeah which ran from
81 to 86 i want to say he had a
superhero it was kind of like a
superhero so he was in that
so that's kind of what he was known for
and so he plays a writer as we said his
name is roger cobb he's a very
successful horror author
uh but he's also a vietnam veteran and
his you know his latest book he wants to
make it kind of like a memoir of his
time in vietnam because apparently he's
got some ptsd issues with something that
happened there that's like haunting him
which you don't find out until later on
in the movie and he's also kind of had
some other shitty things going on in the
past year of his life uh in that his kid
uh jimmy disappeared mysteriously from
this house like his aunt's house
and uh then his wife who was an actress
on a soap opera she ended up divorcing
him even though they seem like they're
still on fairly good terms but he's like
having some problems so then his aunt
who owns this big creepy victorian house
it's not actually creepy it's actually
like really nice and i i couldn't
believe it had a very modern backyard
with a modern swimming pool and a bunch
of cool [ __ ] that you only saw in the
80s
well they built some of that they built
on that is a real house and they did
actually shoot in there um but some of
the yard like didn't look that great so
they had to like bring in landscapers
and like put in a sidewalk and [ __ ] like
that like to get what they wanted okay
um but overall i think they painted the
outside of the house as well so they
must have built that pool modern because
they i think maybe they did well yeah
that would have been a later edition
right but um yeah so so the kid actually
disappeared mysteriously like he's
basically you know the dads they show a
flashback like he sees him in the pool
and then he jumps in the pool to get him
because he thinks he's drowning and then
he can't find him so it's almost kind of
like he's gone in some other dimension
they don't know if he got kidnapped or
like they don't know where he went and
so you know his life has kind of fallen
into the [ __ ] at this point so his
what his uh you know his wife's left him
as i mentioned his aunt who owns this
house commits suicide in the house she
hangs herself that's like the per that's
like the first five minutes of the movie
and uh so since he is her only living
relative he ends up inheriting the house
and even though he's talking to the real
estate agent and the real estate agent
is assuming that he's just gonna sell it
he actually decides um even though his
aunt has died in this house and even
though his son has disappeared from this
house and even though his aunt was
pretty convinced that this place was
haunted he decides he's gonna stay there
because he thinks that it's gonna like
he can have some solitude and like work
on his new book and sort of
exercise some demons
now
subsequently
some pretty crazy [ __ ] starts happening
in this house
um
among which are let's see what ends up
happening first well the first things
that happened like he started [ __ ] he
starts hearing weird noises there's like
noise up in this closet like up in this
bedroom or whatever and he goes up there
and
sometimes it's a regular closet and then
sometimes it's like all black and like
this big [ __ ] monster comes out of
there like this really creepy like
[ __ ] monster comes out there are
doorways or portals to other dimensions
in the damn house pretty much
yeah so it's kind of like from the
outset i think they kind of set it up at
first like you're not really sure
if maybe he's just losing his [ __ ] and
he's just seeing stuff in there um
but honestly i think the whole premise
is that
because one actually i think the first
supernatural thing he sees is he sees
his
aunt's ghost
like he goes up to the room and like
she's standing there like a normal
person and she says the house fooled me
or the house tricked me and it'll trick
you too like i didn't think the house
could trick me but it did so you're led
to believe that
whatever it was that was in the house
like tricked her into seeing things and
made her kill herself you know what i'm
saying so all of the stuff that you see
happened to him in the movie
isn't necessarily real and it isn't
necessarily all in his head either
the house is haunted
but the implication is
that the house
uses your own
[ __ ] against you like your own
nightmares because he starts having like
nom flashbacks
and you know stuff about like he sees
like his kid like waving from a window
and stuff like that because that's you
know where the kid disappeared from so
you're led to believe that the house is
kind of like haunted but in a
personalized kind of way yeah now let me
say something about the nom flashbacks
and the nom story the nom story is
interesting it's part it's it's part of
the whole over overarching story behind
him and the house and what happens and
[ __ ]
big bear coming back or whatever his
name big big big ben coming back
um
but what how vietnam is actually
portrayed the uniforms like in the
missions that they're doing total
[ __ ] totally unrealistic but just
roll with it
well and honestly it is but i don't mind
it because in the context of the movie
the tone is the same yeah the tone of it
is the same and two you're seeing the
vietnam flashbacks filtered through his
memory of them because he's writing
about them and also it's the house
that's like throwing
like curve balls at you yeah because
apparently this house knows what your
weak points are
um so it will kind of like show you
things that it knows will specifically
upset you yeah um you know so i don't
know they don't go too much into that
it's basically just kind of like you
know he sees like you know he sees his
aunt's ghost and that's pretty creepy
and then he sees like this creepy
monster that comes out of this closet
that's sometimes there and sometimes not
he buys all these cameras like he's
gonna like film it yeah but then
sometimes like he tries to film it it's
not there
um and then like he starts like i said
he sees his kid
you know kind of waving so he sees
serious [ __ ] but then he sees like wacky
[ __ ] too because he sees like the
[ __ ] uh swordfish that i guess was
his oh his uncle killed it right yeah um
like at a fishing tournament a long time
ago and it like comes to life like a
billy the big mouth bastard like
it's like it's like mouth is moving and
like [ __ ] like that and he ends up like
shooting it shooting it with a shotgun
yeah because he so so like i said during
that part of the movie it's almost kind
of like they're setting it up like he's
you know just lost it you know what i
mean he's just like crazy and he's
seeing things particularly when you get
this one point where uh his neighbor
he's played by george went is like this
super i really like the interactions
between the two of them because like
george wendt is like so [ __ ] funny in
this and he's like super super nosy like
he just like walks in the house like
with beers like hey what's up and it's
blah blah and he's like just crawling up
his like ass all the time
so he basically straight up steals
um
roger's
like
you know address book or whatever
because like i said his ex-wife is
famous like she's on it so and he knows
so the neighbor knows who she's who she
is so he like calls her
and is like hey you need to come up here
because i think like your ex-husband is
like losing his mind and so she turns up
or so you think
and so you're not really sure if she's
there because then she comes in the
house and she's like oh you know
somebody called me i was worried about
you and blah blah and then like she
bends down and then she comes back up
and she's this big
huge um
what do they even call that i think the
name of the monster like for the movie
they called it the sandy witch because
her name was sandy but she's this big
huge like fat like with these big
[ __ ] lips and like these big like red
fingernails and stuff and it's like so
he shoots it but then you but then like
then it looks like his actual wife is
laying on the porch like he's oh my god
he actually like killed his wife but
apparently he didn't but he really he
thinks that he did so there's all kinds
of illusions in mind control and stuff
yeah so i think that's kind of like the
whole thing is that the house is just
making him see things so you're not it's
not a question of like oh is he crazy or
anything like that it's just it's the
house is working on his fears and is
working on his guilt and his memories
and stuff like that because like i said
in the third act you find out that like
when he was back in nam
and uh you know big ben like got shot up
and then he was just like oh i'm not
gonna make it you need to kill me and
roger couldn't kill him
and then big ben ended up getting like
uh captured by the vietnamese and they
tortured him and it's like he was like
i'll get you roger blah blah so it's
like whether that really happened or not
like that maybe did happen but i think
that roger's like
uh memory of that was like haunting him
and so that's why the house was using
um the big bend character that like came
back all zombified to you know just like
oh i'm the one that kidnapped your son
and i'm the one that did this and that
the other because it's weird i've seen
like a lot of reviews of this movie i
kind of feel like this is one that
a lot of people have like a lot of
affection for it from the 80s because
like i said it's one that was sort of
like a video store staple like because
that cover was so great and it was just
like so iconic and i feel like it was on
cable all the time so it's like i and i
feel like i ended up seeing it like a
zillion times yeah you know for for you
guys that are too young to remember
video stores and blockbuster and [ __ ]
like that
on a friday or saturday night when you
were a teenager you drive down there
with your friend to go get some movies
you probably were going to take three or
four of them
but on friday chances are that the
movies that you wanted to see were gone
so there were second and third echelon
movies and some of them you had already
seen so you get those anyway so you'd
get one that you already saw before
because back in those days you didn't
have streaming on demand you can just
watch whatever the hell you just watch
whatever you want at the time so you're
like well we got to see three movies man
[ __ ] we saw this one but it's good just
get it again
so it was nothing for us and our
generation to watch a movie five six
seven eight times it would happen a lot
especially if it was on cable
well yeah some of those movies on cable
big and saw some of them 20 times oh
yeah because you know every time it was
on if you didn't have anything else
going on you're like oh what the hell
i'll just watch that again yeah and you
were watching it
off and on you'd look at it for about
20-30 minutes and then you do something
else and you're all good part's coming
and then you watch it again
you watch it for a certain scene and you
had the [ __ ] was burned into your mind
it was a different time
yeah and uh
so sometimes a movie that if you saw it
once you didn't like it but if you after
you'd seen it four or five times you
liked it a lot more and this was one of
them
it's kind of like this yeah this is kind
of one like i said i saw like
i kind of feel like a lot of reviewers
like this one like a you know it's kind
of like a forgotten 80s movie because as
i said it's it's tone it's if you're not
used to seeing a lot of 80s movies or
this type of 80s movies like the tone of
it is very strange it kind of like um in
the sense of like
it being a horror comedy but
not like a horror comedy like they would
make nowadays you know what i'm saying
um it just it really gives me that
twilight zone the movie vibe it gives me
a little bit of vibe like the burbs or
something like that where they were
making these kind of really really dark
[ __ ] up stories but then they were
like kind of goofy and cartoonish at the
same time and i kind of feel like that's
a hard tone to pull off so if you're not
really used to that like you can just be
watching this going what the [ __ ] is
going on and i kind of feel like a lot
of reviewers i saw even if they liked
the movie
i don't think they understood
that it was the house that was making
him see a lot of this stuff
yeah
it's funny because even when i was white
i've seen this many times and even
watching it again my mind would still
kind of wander
you know what i mean away from the story
and then be pulled back later because i
think when you've seen things so many
times sometimes you stop paying
attention to it yeah that's true you
know so i can see how maybe a person
who'd never seen this before
maybe their mind wanted a little bit and
didn't quite catch what the movie was
implying
especially because
back in this day they had to they they
kind of had to
the storytelling and the way movies were
edited
were kind of not like movies of today
because they they didn't have the
special effects
to make something totally clear all the
time
there was a certain culture of knowing
what the movie meant by certain things
you know what i mean or just not really
caring
a lot of times
a lot of times we knew what
what the director was
meant because there were other movies at
the time that did kind of the same thing
yeah and you didn't need the exposition
because you're recognizing this ploy
from the movie from another movie that
gave the exposition and in this movie
i'm going no it's it's making him see
ghost images
it's showing him things that are that
are going to be meaningful to him yeah
and they're not there yeah right and
some of this stuff really did happen
because i mean george wentz the neighbor
himself his name's uh howard or harold
i'm sorry in the movie uh he does come
over and he sees the closet monster so
the [ __ ] is there right but um but the
house seems to tailor
uh what it's seeing what what you see
like to what is going to scare you the
most or what's going to upset you right
that kind of came from movies you know
like [ __ ]
amityville horror
and then there's that it's kind of
implied and sometimes in uh evil dead
that some of the things he sees in the
shack didn't actually happen he just
it was just like a ghostly
apparition but then later things do
actually grab him there are zombies yeah
so at least if i remember it correctly i
think in the evil dead this actually now
that you mention it this some parts of
this give me a little bit of an evil
dead too vibe as well it does
particularly the one part where he goes
into the bathroom mirror and that's
almost like lovecraftian for a second
because it's just like this black void
and then these tentacles come out and
then he goes in there and it's just a
big black nothingness and then this like
skull thing with like big bat wings
comes and like shoots him with a shotgun
and stuff like that that's very evil
dead-ish that's what i was going to say
during the during the the the wrap up
you know you know of this video i was
going to say i'll just say it now
um it's kind of like a mixture of evil
dead
and gremlins yeah and twilight's on the
movie
or at least that third that the one with
the with anthony i can kind of see it
yeah uh but
for me it felt more like evil dead and
uh gremlins the tone tone wise gremlins
yeah but story-wise more like evil dead
but not gory like like not over-the-top
gory more like cartoonish yeah um you
know what i mean so it's like like i
said if if that sounds like something
that if i mean if you haven't seen this
because i feel like this is one that
doesn't get talked about all that much
when people bring out bring up 80s stuff
now this is actually streaming on amazon
prime
if you have that i believe it's also on
2b for free and i think the second one
is on there too house 2 the second story
which i also have some affection for
although that's way more wacky and like
way more comedy again the sequels there
are three of them are standalone they
don't have anything to do with uh with
each other so you can watch them all
as separate movies um there was also and
i didn't actually realize this
house three
uh was actually not called house three i
didn't even know this was
the same series it was only called house
three in europe here it was called the
horror show so i actually saw that movie
without even realizing that it was
supposed to be house 3 because like i
said it doesn't have anything to do with
like the first movie now house 4 the
repossession i think is called um
i think i haven't seen it but i
i read that they did actually get
william cat back for that one so maybe
it does have some kind of
link to the first one but none of them
are even like in the same house or
anything like that so it's like not i
mean the second one has that weird like
caterpillar puppy and like a dead pirate
or a prospector with like a crystal
skull
yeah yeah yeah that one's like that
one's [ __ ] crazy the only thing about
the second one that's kind of the same
is that there's a house with like these
doors that pull you into like these
wacky ass dimensions so house three kind
of pulled a troll too
yeah where the movie's not related to
anything else they just gave it a damn
title
i think that's a trip that that the
first troll was called troll two to make
you think there was the first one well
you know this the
boggy creek foggy creek two and the
legend continues was actually boggy
creek three yeah but it's just because
they made a boggy creek too and no one
gave a [ __ ] about it so he's like
goddammit we're gonna
but yeah so like until i didn't even i'd
seen like a house too like many many
times um but i didn't even realize that
there were two more and that they didn't
have anything to do with the first movie
either so you know but yeah so i think
that at least the first two are on uh or
on 2b and the first one's on amazon
prime as well might also be on shutter
i'm actually not sure but yeah if
anything we said if you liked gremlins
if you liked twilight's in the movie if
you like like evil dead this is that
type of
vibe to it you know what i mean so it's
that kind of like sort of cartoony
but also kind of like weird surreal type
of [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah so i
kind of feel like if if that's kind of
your jam and you haven't seen it then
you should probably check it out because
it was like it's really weird and it's
like really entertaining i was i don't
know i was
and i don't know if that's just
nostalgia talking because i saw this
movie so much in the 80s and so i just
have this affection for it it's partly
nostalgia yeah because
we see these movies and they're kind of
comforting because we know the era we
know the thinking that was behind the
movie it kind of takes us back so that's
an element that a young person wouldn't
have although i think some young people
who are into retro [ __ ] would would like
this
yeah oh i definitely would because they
don't really don't make movies like this
anymore
no they don't make and and in a way
they're trying to they need to make
movies like this again yeah just that if
they would it probably wouldn't get much
attention unless it was put out on
shutter
yeah it'd be like a shutter original and
some of the shutter originals are trying
to harken back to this time yeah or
trying to kind of replicate this tone
which like i said you it's you can't do
it like entirely because you know a lot
of the context of the 70s because we
don't live in that era anymore um but i
do like i do respect that people are
trying to like replicate that
yeah that tone from that it's kind of a
comforting feel to it just the way to
describe it yeah
yeah you notice that yeah it's kind of a
comforting feel and i think it's just
because it's
from from our point of view it's so
normal american yeah like 80s middle
class
yeah like back to the future or [ __ ]
like that just like normal american
stuff yeah yeah yeah this definitely has
that uh type of vibe to it too but way
weirder yeah
it's like weird [ __ ] happening in normal
america and that's what you're supposed
to feel yeah yeah yeah that's a good way
of looking at it yeah all right so that
will do it for our review of 1986's
house check it out if you haven't seen
it because i feel like like i said it's
sort of one that doesn't get talked
about a lot and we will see you guys on
the next one
bye